okay please allow me just the briefest
diversion from horrible things happening
the world over and in the united states
to mention something very exciting and
positive which is that the david pakman
show youtube channel
has achieved and surpassed 900
000 subscribers in fact i think we now
are probably closer to 901
uh yeah just shy of 901 000 already this
happened
yesterday during a live stream in fact
rolling over
from 899 000 subscribers
to 900 000 youtube subscribers and so
now the race to 1 million officially
begins now about 18 months ago we were
already starting to look at you know
could we get to a million by election
day it it could happen
18 months out it's sort of hard to know
if things go well
we could maybe hit a million subscribers
before the 2020 election
we still could although we're a little
bit behind right now according to
socialblade based on recent growth
trends
we're expected to hit a million
subscribers on january 9th so that would
be before the inauguration
but about two months after the election
however it's not impossible so rough
numbers we're 97 days from election day
and we're 99 000 subscribers short of a
million so call it you know it's like a
hundred thousand
we need about a thousand thirty new
subscribers a day
from here on out to hit a million by
election day
this actually isn't crazy the last few
weeks we've been getting
1300 a day we only need a thousand
thirty a day
so we just have to hold that and then we
can do it now
this is really wild i was looking back
at old numbers you know what
the david pakman show launched on
youtube a long time ago
and we did it because jenk yuger from
the young turks who i met in 2008 at a
radio uh conference
i told him what i was doing and he said
you know you should throw some cameras
in your studio
start putting the videos on youtube it
could be big youtube could be big that's
what jenk said to me
and so we started filming the show and
it took us
five years to get our first hundred
thousand
subscribers on youtube to go from zero
to a hundred thousand
it took five years the next hundred
thousand
took only a year and five months we then
got our
next hundred thousand and only eleven
months
we then went from 300 000 to 400 000
in eight months then things sort of
slowed down a little
it took us 10 months for the next
hundred thousand
it took us eight months to get to six
hundred thousand
took us another only four months to get
to seven hundred thousand subscribers
seven to eight hundred thousand took
seven months
and it only took us five months to go
from eight hundred thousand to nine
hundred thousand subscribers
we have just over three months
to get to a million it would be the
fastest gain
of a hundred thousand subscribers since
we've started
but let's go for it let's go for it and
by the way i also want to start hearing
ideas from people about
what to do to celebrate getting to one
million um
send me ideas a few people wrote in and
said i should
dye my hair some color and it should be
subject to maybe people voting on what
the color would be i mean i guess i
would maybe do that my hair color
doesn't really lend itself i'd have to
probably totally bleach it first to dry
it i don't know that that's particularly
good
you know some of these chemical elements
so to speak aren't exactly the best
my guess is i'm not ruling it out but my
guess
is people can probably come up with
something more clever
than just dying my hair to do it one
million
youtube subscribers and meanwhile
fortunately the show is growing on other
platforms as well
so i i'm not doing like a full state of
the show address here for you today
but we have surpassed 40 000 followers
on our twitch channel which is great the
audio podcast
is uh has grown like 20
per month for the last two three months
which has really given us a big big
boost
and it's extraordinary to see more
people engaging with us on that platform
so a lot of good things needless to say
send me your ideas for what to do to
celebrate 1 million subscribers
assuming we get there i don't know that
it's a matter of if i think it's more a
matter of when
i want it to be before election day
imagine if it was on election day
imagine if
as we defeat donald trump if we do we
surpass
one million subscribers i'd have to blow
out memberships for two bucks a year
right i'd have to do something
completely unprecedented if that
happened uh but send me your ideas and
we'll follow up and discuss more